well new york's official count of more
than 8
000 nursing home deaths could be up to
50 percent higher bringing the potential
tally closer to 13
000 maybe more that's according to a
bombshell report from the new york
attorney general's office revealing
the state severely under counted it also
addresses governor cuomo's controversial
mandate for nursing homes
to take in covet-19 patients finding it
quote may have put
residents at increased risk of harm in
some facilities
here now exclusively former new york
governor george pataki governor
good of you to come on sir we appreciate
it i find the numbers here striking as
i'm sure you do
50 of kova debts under counted the state
attorney general said this the following
as the pandemic in our investigation
continue it is imperative
that we understand why the residents of
nursing homes in new york
unnecessarily being the key word
suffered
at such an alarming rate and yet there
have been
little if any consequences i mean you
have the governor getting awards and
praise and book deals
your thoughts uh trace this is a new low
uh for months uh legislators everyone
has been trying to get those numbers
from the governor's office and they've
just stonewalled
and now we know why uh and the reason is
because they were misrepresenting it
from the beginning
you know i know a little bit about
leading in a crisis and you want to do
two things
you want to make the right decisions or
if you make a decision that
you question and you change it quickly
and the second thing is you want to
communicate
honestly with the people on both of
those fronts
the cuomo administration has failed
miserably they made the wrong decision
on nursing homes they refuse to collect
it
correct it when it was pointed out and
now it appears they've lied to the
people of new york about what those
consequences actually were this is
inexcusable yeah we should note that
governor cuomo his office have not yet
responded to this report
but the governor did say this yesterday
on a different network watch
incompetent government kills people
incompetent government kills people more
people
died than needed to die in covet
that's the truth incompetent government
can kill people uh this is not a joke
and more people died here than needed to
he's not talking about himself but he is
correct incompetent government can kill
people
trace that's one of the few things
governor cuomo got right
uh and he should have been looking at
the mirror when he said it because he's
the one
who dictated that nursing homes take
coveted positive patients
uh when they were desperately saying
they were not qualified not capable of
dealing with it
uh i remember i was one of the first to
say this is idiotic and it's going to
kill people
i went on twitter for 47 straight days i
was on there saying
stop the man that stopped killing our
most vulnerable and he wouldn't change
the policy and then finally at the end
it just quietly
was reversed without any comment but
it's not just that you look at today
today less than half nursing home staff
in new york state
have been vaccinated you know they they
had a priority on nursing home staff
from the beginning and yet
because of the incompetence it just came
out today that less than half have been
vaccinated in nursing homes the staffs
this has just been a disaster from the
beginning it's
kind of ironic that the press looks at
him and says what a great job
when all you have to do is look at the
fact that we have almost twice as many
deaths as in florida
and see how incompetently the qualm
administration has handled this crisis
new york congresswoman elise stefanik
said the following quoting here
um this is a massive corruption scandal
at the highest level
of new york state government there needs
to be subpoenas issued immediately and
cuomo and his entire senior team
on all documentation and internal
communications on how they
orchestrated to hide these numbers from
the people
of new york the question is will there
be consequences
in your estimation for this kind of
governing last thoughts absolutely right
there has to be an investigation and
there has to be subpoenas
it has to be the state legislature it
has to be the attorney general
and i would i believe federal officials
should look at
this as well you can't trust the cuomo
administration to investigate
itself they did that at the beginning
they conducted their own
internal investigation and concluded
their policy of putting copic positives
in nursing home patients wasn't a
problem it was the staff that was the
problem
it was just a cover-up now we know that
the numbers have been covered up this
demands
a subpoena investigation to hold them
accountable
uh and i hope it comes quickly and i
hope it's aggressive
yeah former governor george pataki thank
you for coming on governor we appreciate
it
thank you chase